how did that go from being a doctor and
being well
known to being an uber driver it's
called the ball fitness
and the paul sport is the different
stuff if you want to grow
in the new country when you move you
have to be prepared to
what would they think of in ukraine if
they heard all this you guys have your
own
own universe here really absolutely they
are trying to
make people more dependent happy wife
happy life what can i say
more because i'm 50. and this is the one
of the
pros of the united states they call it
hachipuri
in ukraine no one can even think this
way
russian food in a romanian restaurant
with the jews
owner i mean the bazaar you know
is it good
russian kindergarten here so this is a
whole another russian zone
[Music]
all right
not a fancy one okay
natalie's quite a character this is fun
interesting always interesting seeing it
through another person's eyes
all right what do we got here uh world
marketing cafe yeah
i mean if you miss russia or ukraine you
can see it right there you can
feel like i'm in i don't know i'm in the
bazaar
you know is it good so you can check
everything
ukrainian or russian sushi and see
michiki
it's a mitch you guys love that stuff
yeah
and shock a lot everything everything
that you can buy
wow in russia you can buy right there
so you got your mushroom your grey billy
gribbly
and here we go i love your pickled foods
yeah
you can grab the
ukrainian right here ski tour
my dad is from indian my mom is from
russia
okay you speak russian uh yes
you speak you speak hindi no russian in
english
uh yes russian english oh cool you like
this place
yes and this is grishka
yeah that's good buckwheat
[Music]
bye bye what's your youtube channel name
okay
[Music]
you can buy even georgian wine or
soviet champagne soviet champagne
you see yeah wow
you guys have your own own universe here
really absolutely
[Music]
everything here what's your friend's
name
ah it's john why not john
john but here in miami i can call it
carlos also juan carlos call it juan
carlos
carlos and carlos and john do you rock
the full
adidas kit vitaly no
russian mafia system this is the point
so
in order to if you want to grow in the
new country when you move
you have to be prepared to put
some uh how to say it not the shutdown
but when when everything drops in your
life
so i mean uh i was uh what do you mean
everything drops in your life
i mean uh like just
my example so i was uh i was a famous
doctor in ukraine and i
did some um tv shows i was an
expert so on the tv show so
right i mean i have my own like a level
of popularity or something like that
and self-actualization and then when you
move to another country no one knows you
so you have to start from the scratch
with what i'm saying
what you would you start with i start
with the this is the spoken here
i start with the many others i start
with
doing some uber a lift and
how does delivery how did that go from
being a doctor and being well
known to being an uber driver yeah i i
was prepared
that that the treat because i'm not just
a dog and
i was in ukraine i'm a psychiatrist
okay and uh here i i decided
in ukraine so i switched my uh
own practice from the medical practice
to more healthy practice like uh working
with the people with motivation they
call it life and business coaching
yeah yeah i did because i also have uh
economical degree
yep so i just decided to combine to
all these two degrees into one point so
i was prepared i mean i was
psychologically prepared for this
uh so so how how quick could you go up
you went from
uber driver and then how how quick did
that i mean
maybe two years or something like that
so you just basically
put your head down work did whatever two
years yeah until you can get to this
point
and uh i'm really happy that i have a
great wife because we did it together
and this is the also the point because
she started doing the
private classes like your feet and
something like that
and then we we got some lawn and opened
the bases and start
started to grow so you didn't come here
with a ton of money you're not one
people on the coast no no no
wow here is it's easier to
to uh to get paid for for your
work i mean if you work hard
you will definitely get your income i
mean you got your feedback
because in ukraine many people used to
live in just for surviving
you know you get the you get your salary
at the end of the month and then you
spend all this money for
for some payments for everything and you
you have nothing
but don't you think a lot of people live
like that here
i think 90 percent month to month and 90
percent
90 yeah here
the idea is the same but the numbers
is different ah okay the numbers are
different so
i mean here the same the same structure
so you have to
you know you got the car so you have to
pay for the car you have to pay for
uh the more you get the more you have to
pay every month
yeah but but for me here is better
because if you're willing to work
you will definitely get what you're
expecting for
gotcha and you feel like the system's on
your side
uh i feel that the system not against
you
because in ukraine you know
people used to to thinking that and they
are right
because the government and the irs and
everything
every all these agencies they're trying
you know to cut the money from you
here though too right here but here it's
absolutely officially i mean
it is written so
you know what you're going to pay so
it's just
you just got some some weird papers like
you have to pay for permit in order to
get the permit in order to get the
license to be
to be allowed to get the permit and you
have to pay
right this sum so
you can do it online so it's pretty easy
okay so but at least you know where your
money is more predictable oh it's more
it's more predictable it's it seems like
most immigrants like you usually do well
in this system
as you you ha you have something to
judge it against
and you you can maneuver things better
than someone that's just
lived here and knows nothing else yeah
because they they have nothing to
compare with
got the car yeah and start driving and i
feel
that i don't need to avoid some
pots and pits yeah for her on the road
because in ukraine i used to
drive in the car like in a computer game
so you have to
follow the traffic rules you have to
follow the traffic signs
and you also have to follow not to get
into some hall so
and it was really nice but when
when people live here for for
many years and they just used to think
that everywhere
in the world they have the same roads
yeah and they have the same
infrastructure they have the same
and everything is good yeah what do you
say to those who
who are grew up in the us and complain
and i'm talking about stop complaining
guys just stop complaining begin to
begin begin
work it's because the the work
if you got a work or if you got a job
it's
the best way to to stop complaining
yeah that's true it's hard because you
don't have time for
complaining if you if you work hard
because here if you work hard you can do
wherever you want but if if you
uh the sooner or later you will become
successful
[Applause]
i mean if you do uh for example if you
do plan b
and you're yeah that you can be very
lucrative yeah yeah
that's true but yeah i agree in in
theory for most if you have enough
skills
right you're not a native speaker yeah
absolutely yeah and you're pulling it
off i love it
and i'm still working i mean on my
english
but you're doing well
[Music]
so what do you i mean what do you
think's going on right now vitaly
i think they are uh now it's
we're talking about the world feeling
weird at the moment and they're trying
to
make people more dependent on the
on the government on the government so
they're trying to code this
um freedom they trying to
get the freedom from the people and
they're trying to make it
like a dependent from from the
government so
we can we can say like if i i'm in a
government i can say
you guys just go and vote for me so and
people just
just do this because because they don't
have
uh their own choices
or something like that do you feel like
uh the like people are either getting
richer or poor
right the richest people they are going
richer and the poor
uh everyone else going to be
poor but and this is the one of the
pros of the united states because being
being poor here it's okay i mean
you can you can grab the free insurance
you can get the free stuff and some food
stamps and some social
um help so i mean
but the problem is that they if you're
super
rich you can avoid all these taxes and
everything
because you can hire lawyers and
accountants
right accountants right lawyers and you
can avoid paying these taxes and
everything
and if if you're poor then no one can
uh want every anything from you because
you don't have anything you can
use all these free health insurance and
everything so
uh according to this the most
important part of the society is the
middle class
because the this is the only there is
the only people who spay in texas
who feed everyone else and so
i think in uh in the near future they're
going to cut the cut more from the
middle class
so what is happening right now it's not
in my opinion it's not really good for
the middle class
right but okay if the middle class is
paying all the taxes why would they want
to cut the middle class
they're trying uh they're trying to to
get more
from the middle class and they are i
mean in the mid then the middle class
become the poor class so
they just disappeared so i mean they are
done no one wants to become
poor from to to go from the from the
middle class to the poor class right but
as as we can see right now the people
have to close the businesses and
everything because they're
they don't have a way right to manage
this stuff so but what you're saying
earlier it's almost like you have to get
to this level
to like to win the game now where you
can hire the accountant
and that account manipulates whatever
needs to be manipulated
legally right legally yeah and you pay
less and you avoid this and you avoid
that but if you're the middle class and
you're getting taxed
you know through your paycheck you don't
have weight you're getting into paying
yeah yeah you get hammered
yeah it's messy you have to pay it's
unfair
i mean if you're earning for example if
your income
20 000 per year you can get
child for free i mean you you don't have
to pay for
for the delivery for the child delivery
um
what do you how do you think people
would what would they think of in
ukraine if they heard all this
in ukraine we have i mean in ukraine no
one
can even think this way because we don't
have an insurance at
all so in ukraine you can you can i mean
you can trust only yourself so
if you have some savings yeah and you
got
sick so you will be treated
anyway you just you just go to
to to to die there's nothing
that you can do if you don't have the
money you don't yeah so you want the
only way
is to pay the money so we don't have we
we
have this free medicine but it's not
free obviously
so you cannot afford the normal life
here for two thousand per month
well two thousand dollars selling yeah
so the only ways to do something uh
on your own like unknown business or
something like that
or do many businesses at the time or
because something like that that is the
only the way
so if you go to to work as a cashier
in public yeah it's not gonna work so
you
yeah i mean you can just live in a
small apartment and just afford the food
and something like that so
you would never get some good great car
or something like fancy or something
like that so
you have to do something more it's not
you see this is the this is the point of
our studio
this is the main idea it's not the only
uh
the premises when you can work out
it's the community oh yeah when the
people meet
what they can do you know the girls can
do some gossip stuff you know
and something like that so it's friendly
community it's not a
it's not the gym okay so we can
it's the hollywood hollywood florida if
you're in hollywood florida
need a good dance studio flamingos
[Music]
so now it's the private class so they
are just warming the muscles
and then they will start doing the hard
work
that's the new way to improve the body
it is called the can go jumping
yeah never seen that
[Music]
it's always good to see when someone's
doing something
[Music]
you you teach technique right you teach
techniques yes
and then there's this is there like a
specific routine they do
or how does it work um
[Music]
i think most people think that like
whole they see full dancing and they're
thinking strip club
yeah but but it's not about these two
cups that balls
use might be used for for the fitness
right right
it's called it is called the pull
fitness
and the whole sport there's the
different stuff i mean
yeah i mean you know that's the point
it's great for the different type of
muscles you know to do this
kind of piece and it's really hard to do
something
but trust me it's not it's impossible i
mean
i tried different kind of times and
no no my point was to you guys
a lot of people think pole dancing is
associated only with strip clubs
this is an actual class this is an
actual sport yeah
who already 60 years old and they
already grandmas but they come here to
have fun and to relax
that's why it's a good business that's
why it's running good
it's your hobby yes so you do you do
this you know
and then it becomes my business
so you do this personally you do the
school dancing
i used to do but now i already have a
few instructors who work here because
now they already have 10 different
classes
and have you gotten vitali on the poll
yet will we do it
and i'm on the paperwork
natalie making sure the paperwork's okay
alexander cheering everyone on would you
say you never went to a gym in 20 years
20 years
i haven't been in a gym and i saw her
advertising on instagram and i just
loved it
it's hard because i'm 50. so
you don't know but i'm getting there
slowly it's an amazing workout huh
it's an amazing and she's amazing i mean
it helps you with your self team and all
that
it's really nice are you gonna be doing
that next time of course i will
did you all come from gymnastic
backgrounds yeah
but i actually like i never really liked
gymnastics or anything they started like
trying to convince me to come here and i
didn't want to because i didn't think it
was gonna be fun
the first class after that like i was
like i want to come every day
so what do you what do you feel by doing
it i mean
i think it's fun like i don't know
because we're here with our friends so
it's kind of like uh
like we get to hang out we get to see
each other we get to like
and work out yeah i'm happy for having
this opportunity like
that we moved to the united states and
i'm happy for the chain
for these changes of our life really so
i think it's the most important part in
the life that you can do what you like
and i'm really happy with my wife she
feels
um self actual
fulfilled with she's doing what she
likes
so what can you say
happy life happy wife happy life what
can i say
more this is super nice
[Music]
poppy your puppy
okay we're off to a restaurant armenian
restaurant just want to say one thing
uh it always impresses me when
someone moves from one country to
another you know english isn't their
native language
they don't know the system you know when
they first got here they didn't know the
system
they didn't have the connections and
they pull it off they make it happen
they make their dream come true and
they're doing what they love it's
beautiful all right flamingo
dance fitness studio you got a little
bit of everything in there
what is that class now dance and
yoga outside strip dance yo-yo always
better
howdy's better okay out of that are you
ready to
eat some russian food
i'm ready uh russian food in a romanian
restaurant
with the juice owner
[Music]
i like this kind of european style when
you come to the restaurant and they put
the clothes on the table so
you know they they're really into
details
we are in our slavic community
uh on the one hand but we are
to be inside the american community so i
mean i mean
on the one hand we do the business here
and we are following all the rules
like illegal and everything and on the
other hand
we we we are not ready and i think it's
a good
part a far that we are not ready to
you know to just to cancel our culture
so it's it's a part of our life why not
we are trying to to try the georgian
food they call it hachapuri
like a pizza but only with cheese only
with cheese and a lot of cheese
that's nice it's good
okay here we have chicken sleek
which is chicken barbecue special sauce
barbecue something like that but this is
the jordan
you will feel it it's the different one
it's not the barbecue
now we have one other thing here
sweaters
[Music]
so you make these sweaters yes it's all
handmade
by very good professional ukrainian
monsters
and here we use only best
quality street and all materials
and you ship to the us yes we ship it to
eures
and we already ship it all over the
world and you
design this yeah yes you do
of course wow
[Music]
so you guys work a lot yeah in order to
get paid you have to work harder but i
said before i mean
it's not easy but here in the united
states
if you work hard you you would get
normal money and those sweaters are
going for like 200
sweater that's a that's a good price
and handmade yeah what are you doing
with this vitaly what's going on here
come on
okay guys end of the road a nice little
glimpse into a different
side of miami in this miami series i'm
trying to hit all these different angles
the cuban perspective the venezuelan the
brazilian
now the ukrainian slash russian hope you
enjoyed that
i was a lot of fun i also want to
mention
if you're in this area oksana has that
amazing studio
battalion is a life business coach
and they also make sweaters handmade in
ukraine
delivered to your home very beautiful
styles
that's it guys hope you enjoyed that
thank you guys thank you for watching
thank you
until the next one perfect
that's the top level thank you so much
i love it i love these stories let's
grab some food
all right all right we're gonna get some
food